tiens et joe dassin joe dassin ne peut
pas chanter aujourd'hui il a quand même
la gentillesse vous présenter un de ses
camarades va vous expliquer sa lui-même
quand même très bien
bonsoir ici jourdain sont aujourd'hui je
ne peux pas chanter mais je vous ai
présenté un ami à moi je ne sens pas
parce que ma chanson fait 17h47 et sans
ballon et mon ami s'appelle pierre
perret ils sont une chanson sur un vieux
couple parce qu'il est très dur quand on
some de se retrouver à 2 et d'être vieux
alors monsieur pierre perret
blanchon les mariés depuis 40 berges
jeter ce qu'elle a de plus comme quand
j'avais 20 ans
pour dire que les années mon torpiller
la sptr je vois tu as des lumbagos dans
la cuve en pas au fond
mais qu'est-ce qu'on sport la gueule
quand on essayait de se perdre
elle que pour s'exciter on a acheté
union
ce que j'ai réussi c'est [ __ ] la
gueule par terre en faisant la brouette
sur le petit guéridon
blanc
show ma blanche
demande pas pardon
si tes cheveux ont pris
la couleur de ton nom
on a mis nos couleurs dans des boîtes à
tendresse
et nous baiser culotte dans des paniers
que
mais c'est pas la routine dans notre
vieillesse on se fait l'amitié à
n'importe quelle heure
et tu m'abandonnes une nuit de
recherches cuisse
lorsque j'allais frotter mes fesses à
d'autres dollars
j'ai compris très vite et sans comme le
disent qu'ils les deux meilleurs ni que
le creux de tes bras
blanc
shaw a blanche
sur notre vieil amour toutes nos pattes
d'oie
son patte de velours
voilà et puis nous avons un français un
français moyen
je vais tomber la veste je vais lui
mettre un béret c'est l'exemple type du
râleur c'est un monsieur pour lequel je
mets donc le béret parce qu'il a les
cheveux plutôt noir et moi j'ai pas
tellement des cheveux noirs
il ya un gros ventre j'ai peur aux
hommes de m parce que moi je l'est déjà
il a des petites lunettes rondes il
raconte l'histoire d'un mec souvent
évidemment monsieur coluche giscard
jusqu'à tuer sur une pente ce vous bon
quand tu écoutes je tourne je suis rien
n'y faisait rien toi je disais rien mais
tu cherches earache bon suspens quand
même pas nous prendre pour des cons tu
vois pas ce qu'on encaisse de tulle et
ussel raisons à l'appui
chirac s'en va et raymond barre qu'est
ce qui reste un pour nous prendre pour
des cons quand même voix ce mois de
fusion qu'à voir il ya des choses qui
sont franchement à cause de lui là bas
c'est par exemple c'est à dire les
hôpitaux à cause de lui un peu aussi
parce que moi par exemple mais qui se
fait cassé le col du fémur toi là bas
c'est malin
le mec qui sait pas que le colis je
viens c'est la tuer se plante il rigole
pas c'est drôle ça à la mecque ce
festival du fémur peuvent ne pas s'en
faire naître un autre à cause du plan
chios tu as non vers le mec il
bon moi je rigole quand par exemple jean
les copains à moi de m c'est un borgne
il aurait fallu deux perdrix michael et
le match était pas content l'oeuvre soit
en attente son véhicule encore plus tout
notre forme s'ils s'étaient fait couper
le pied
ils ont rattrapé tous les rituels et le
flicage et au comptant à la route a fait
trois ans que tu m'as dit ugo mola
riders ils n'auraient plus le cerveau
j'ai rien dit mais les pieds je m'en
sers merde